para su primera visita al continente
europeo desde el asesinato del
periodista amalia giorgi por agentes
sauditas en 2018 en estambul el príncipe
heredero fue recibido al elíseo por
emanuel mccu a quien agradeció por la
cálida acogida este viernes el elíseo
publicó un informe explicando que
durante su encuentro hablaron de mitigar
los efectos de la guerra en ucrania y
ayudar a europa a diversificar su
suministro energético
hay dos grandes principios el primero es
ser capaz de construir una agenda que
defienda los intereses de francia en la
región el segundo ser capaces de
compartir la posición francesa respecto
a la guerra en ucrania requiere tener
intercambios no importa la forma no
importan los interlocutores en medio del
conflicto ucraniano los países europeos
buscan urgentemente nuevas fuentes de
petróleo y gas pero en occidente esta
visita que llega dos semanas después del
encuentro del príncipe con el presidente
joe biden es fuertemente criticada
mohamed bin salman es acusado por los
servicios de inteligencia
estadounidenses de haber registrado el
asesinato del periodista
washington
ghosn como diablos van a persuadir macro
no bailen al mundo entero que apoyen a
ucrania por la democracia por el estado
del derecho porque se ponen a unos
crímenes de guerra como los que está
llevando a cabo rusia cuando se arriman
y chocan los puños con un dictador
brutal y otros como él en medio oriente
que invaden otros países y bombardean a
los civiles menudistas
las asociaciones de derechos humanos
critican la falta de coherencia del
discurso occidental y denuncian la
fuerte movilización contra la guerra en
ucrania y el silencio que reina cuando
se trata de la guerra en yemen un
conflicto en el que arabia saudita ha
liderado una coalición para combatir los
rebeldes hutíes y que ha dejado más de
300.000 muertos desde 2015